David so was telling me about a time
that you guys went to a movie premiere
or something and then there were like
Chinese opening credits and then you
yelled out I can't read this
that's prison Joe
[Music]
all right um Joe this one's for you it's
your boy Larry Nasser hey Joe's boy
huh he's my favorite OB GYN ever Nazir
oh Dad guy
hahaha
I was like why me
I mean Mr homie dude that's where I love
you there's your boy he got stabbed in
prison after a comment he allegedly made
while watching Wimbledon what was the
comment do they say that he said
something curvy yeah to the and in his
they're like what'd you say that's crazy
that even inmates are like [__] this guy
it was a [__] pedophile well pedals
are the lowest of the low in jail but
isn't he with other pedophiles in his
cell or like in his block
that's a good question I mean maybe this
guy's like a different tier of pedophile
maybe there's like a whole ranking
system within the pedophile to them
they're like he's taking it too far yeah
yeah other pedals are like so context
just in case anybody's been living under
a rock this is the former USA Gymnastics
Team Doctor Who people including like
Simone biles and stuff like that said
that they you know he like did very very
inappropriate things like decades work
he has like infinite counts
molested it like hundreds of girls yeah
yeah and uh apparently the comment that
he made while watching and this is
alleged while watching the women's
Wimbledon tennis tournament with other
inmates was uh quote I wish there were
girls playing
wait so there's dudes playing he's like
I wish they were winning I think they
were women I think he was ew dude oh God
that's so much worse than what I was
thinking yeah I thought it was dudes
playing he's like I wish it was girls
but then he wanted just younger oh I
guess so that allegedly but that comment
according to the source there led a
fellow inmate to go to Nasser cell later
in that day and then stab him at least
six times with a manufactured weapon wow
but I wonder if this has anything to do
with the whole Epstein [__] because
they're homies you know Epstein when he
was in jail he specifically seeked out
this dude's lawyer because he needed
someone to vent and talk to is that what
makes it or like they were actually
connected well because he knew that this
guy's lawyer was getting him out of some
pedophile [__] so he's like yeah he's a
pedal
specialist
dude who's the best
people we gotta find out who the who's
the Sean King of pedos who's the Michael
Jordan of pedal lawyers and kill that
[__] let's find the Shapiro bro
because I'm sure we can find out the
guy's name of of who Larry Nazareth is
and what makes you want to defend a
pedophile and didn't and didn't Larry
nasser's lawyer technically fail yeah
why would you want him well he just was
like Larry I can't help you Larry I
can't Jerry epson's Jerry Jerry or
Jeffrey yeah Jerry Jerry Jerry what do
we just call him Jerry
man
if it was another hit job because it was
like he knows too much he might squeal
this little [__] ass it's been a minute
though right like
this was news like what live that's
honestly what he said is not as bad as I
thought it would be maybe it was the way
he said remember this is a legend
quotations maybe he was there and he's
like
you know what I mean I mean you don't
know how he said it just nudging
everyone in the room yeah yeah that's
the thing though is that what bothers me
is like you're Larry Nazar Nazir Nazar
oh don't make it ethnic no is it is it
Nazir I'm just reading it as an American
phonetically Nazar so this dude is
watching girls women play tennis and he
just he can't shut the [__] up about
this like he can't keep it to him yeah
you know he's obviously in prison but to
just say that to somebody else that you
like may not know or just can you
imagine this fool what if it's not even
about the comment what if he was just
being annoying they're like we're trying
to watch the tennis game yeah and then
he's all like he keeps talking and [__]
they're like I'm gonna kill you after
this yeah maybe that watching movies in
prison is kind of dangerous you can't
even talk or say anything I watch out
behind you ladies I'm sorry I ruined the
movie
that's scary Remember When Johnny was
here and he's talking about how they
were watching earbud though yeah really
inspiring movies about like animals and
stuff that's nice yeah ruining the
ruining the movie in prison probably is
a big deal yeah
well they were watching the women's
tennis game and then there was probably
somebody that was in love with one of
the girls and and he made a comment I
wish they were little girls and he's
like [__]
[__] woman
absolutely because he survived huh yeah
what the dude this guy is a cockroach
it's David so is tell me about a time
that you guys went to a movie premiere
or something and then they were like
Chinese opening credits and then you
yelled out I can't read this [__]
that's
wow
[Laughter]
remember that
no that's the best part he's like I have
no recollection I just used to talk
whatever was on my mind wow
I saw that part of the podcast I texted
David right away I was like you know
what's funnier David Goes what I was
like you got you didn't know Joe back
then so you thought Joe says I can't
read this [__] because it's Chinese I'm
like I know Joe and the reason why he
said that is he forgot his glasses but
he's blaming
we're being out of focus
that's probably more true that's way
better yeah I forgot his glasses and
he's blaming the screen that he can't
read it I can't read this [__] so much
better dude
that makes way more sense because I'm
you know because I'm like why would I
say that of course I can't read Chinese
that'll be the stupidest thing to say
but that makes way more skills like I
don't remember that oh I remember that
we first try to hanging with David
together yeah because David said he
didn't really know you yet he was like
what the [__] and the funny thing is is
that a film festival so everyone's kind
of like
those Film Festival it was a brain a
turtleneck like oh my God
right I grew up going to a certain kind
of theater where the culture was
different we all [__] talked that was
the thing cardina AMC yeah we everybody
just taught it's interactive
bro it's a it's a thing and then later I
was like oh this is this is not how it's
if you go to any [__] movie theater
like like everyone's talking dude I went
to you talked to the screen it's a thing
I went with my family to watch Passion
of the Christ
biggest mistake ever Oh Long Beach yeah
Long Beach Center we went and like
people were yelling Passion of the
Christ when when when Judas betrayed
Jesus which we all know was gonna happen
yeah people were like
on to my God
[Laughter]
which is the right response oh you think
Mel Gibson sitting in the back of
theater like that's what we wanted to
tell you that's what we wanted focus
groups and Long Beach we're killing it
they responded all the right ways dude I
didn't know how to [__] act I
remember back in the day like when we
watched just any show or movies like we
would we're all talking to the TV
like you guys didn't do that [__]
growing up nah I fell asleep huh I fell
asleep all the time
was it dark you just go out the only
person that did that was my mom but she
was always asking questions it would
piss me the [__] off that is the [__]
worst dude that's worse though why why
do you do that why are you wait I'm like
just they're gonna tell you why watch
the [__] mysterious for a reason
I hate driving a car
you know what's funny though in those
scenarios I've never seen my my father
so patient and just answer every
question wow he danced probably just so
used to it this I was like this man is a
good guy yeah because I'm looking at my
mom like shut the [__] up and watch the
[__] movie if you just watch the
answers right there yeah just wait but
maybe she can't deduce it is that a mom
thing all moms do it my mom does that
[__] yeah it's crazy moms are [__]
annoying
especially when they call you back to
back while you're doing something
doesn't that kill your boner yeah you're
just like
why do you even pick up
what your Social Security card's in the
mail okay thank you Mom
I'm jacking off now you gotta play with
it to go back up and like God oh I just
wanted to let you
coming over for dinner back to back
that's tough bro I think it's safe to
say Larry Nasser is probably being
annoying yeah he looks annoying I saw
his picture he does look annoying he
looks like a pedal what if everyone was
jacking it to the Wimbledon games and
then when he said I wish it was girls
and everyone's boners just went away and
he went oh we need to kill this
[__] right now oh they're all
just gay okay that's what you said right
with the bone around went down after
watching the tennis no no they're all
Jack little adult women because of what
he said not because it's hey your social
security card game my bad my bad
so let's go around the room you guys
think Larry's a good guy Ryan go first
if I was I think I think that would be
like the last moment of being like a
good guy in jail it's like you could
have murdered like 300 people but where
you draw the line is pedal and then so
people like everyone has their own
morality right because they not be like
yeah [__] deal drugs or whatever but
so then
that would be like if you're if you're
in like prison for life and it's just
like that's just not Justice man you
[__] over 300 girls are like whatever
I think you need to die is that that's
bottom of the Barrel in prison right
those are like the lowest guys and he
looks like a little rat dude he looks
like a little weasel doesn't he what
what is the hierarchy of prison I heard
it was cop killers at the top that's the
dopest yeah yeah yeah that's like the
top tier yeah that's the top I would
imagine that so that's the valedictorian
cops who are cop killers at the very
topic is cop killers
4.0 yeah
who who has the the gold band over there
the valedictorian's the cop killer yeah
yeah what what's under the gang leaders
the mafia leaders like of the of the
different races yeah but I bet some of
those guys kill cops too so then they
become they get double they get done
they have this they have their guys kill
cops for them you know what I mean they
order the hit they get to decorate their
[__] cap and [__] I don't know and
the bottom of barrel is probably Larry
child crime yeah my boy Larry dude child
crimes I hate that well yeah hopefully
the next couple weeks maybe he'll like
suffer a bad injury or like an infection
he'll die or something that feels like a
green light thing too like I bet you
like when the stabbing happened it was
one of those like the guards
oh hell yeah it did say that several
inmates ran into nasser's cell to take
the suspect off of the former doctor to
hide them probably yeah maybe maybe
maybe maybe but uh you know what they do
sometimes is they infect the knives that
they make in jail
so then you get an infection and die
bacteria blade after you do the stabs
you gotta really make somebody that's
like some Vietcong [__] I mean they used
to do that in the the old school like
Roman days or Warrior days like they
would just [__] on their [__] sword
walking around with [__] sword
everyone's sources smell like [__] oh
god oh
dude can you imagine your homie like you
can hold my sword like God damn I smell
so bad you [__] in the sh you [__] in
the sheath so every time it goes
it recharges that's smart prison tips
falling right like a fountain pen you
dip it in your ass I thought you dip it
one two here we go one two can you
imagine how stank War used to be
dude no deodorant why they fight oh hell
yeah they don't even change dude I found
out have been a scholar maybe yeah just
read poems in a [__] toga I'd rather
be the Catapult guy that's behind the
wall all right being an arrow dude
catapult guys probably the best job this
guy cut the rope it just launch it and
then just go home easy
[Music]
foreign